hello everybody this is peter cooper
from the ncbi and just want to welcome
you to today's webinar on ncbi data sets
uh eric cox is also here who is one of
the technical people from
data sets as well and he can help answer
some of those questions
but i'll pass it over to newella now
thanks peter
today i'm going to talk to you about a
new resource at ncbi called ncbi
datasets
and it's a new resource for making it
easier to access
sequence data and tbi and today i'm
going to go through
accessing data for genomes and genes
so just to give you an overview of the
presentation i'll first describe what is
ncbi databases since it's a new product
and then i'll go over what type of data
you can find in data sets
and then i'll go into detail about how
you can get two to two of these data
sets
the genomes data set and the genes data
set and i'll describe what those data
sets are composed of
and also how you access that data we
offer different methods for accessing
genome and gene data we have web
interfaces and we also have command line
tools
so i'll spend some time describing the
data sets and the interfaces through
this powerpoint slide and then i'll
do a live demo of both our web interface
and our command line tool
so first what is dataset datasets is a
new resource it's aimed at making it
easier for users to find ncbi sequence
data and to do this we are developing
new web and programmatic interfaces
we are not a database ourselves we're
just a group that is making it easier
for people to find data that is in ncbi
we're a new project and
so we are we are limited right now to
data
for genomes and for genes and we have a
special sars cov2 data set
and i want to make a point that we are a
project that's in very active
development
so if for anyone that has been using
datasets you'll notice that we
do make changes on a very regular basis
and
we make these changes based on feedback
from our users so we love to hear from
you and we love to hear what works what
doesn't work
and what you would like to see data sets
do in the future please please contact
us
if you have any issues or questions
so the first data set i'm going to talk
about is our genome data set
and um what sort of distinguishes data
from other ways of retrieving data at
ncbi
is that we deliver data in as a package
so for a genome data set this seems like
a very simple request the
user may come in and want the human
genome but the human genome is actually
a complex package of different data
types
it consists of the genome fasta sequence
that's the
same sequence for the chromosomes as
well as those unlocalized and unplaced
uh sequences sequences that have not
been placed with the with
a particular chromosome or um
or are placed on a chromosome
so it also includes the organelle so
mitochondrial sequences
um so that's the genome sequence and
then there's also the express genome
there's the transcript fasta sequences
there's the protein sequences
and then there's also metadata that goes
along with that describing
the source material for the for the
particular genome and all the other
attributes that go along with that
package and then there's also the
annotation files
so users want annotation files in
different formats there can be
gss3 formats there can be gtf format and
gbsf format
so what's one thing that datasets is
doing is that a user can come in and ask
for something simple like human genome
and they can get options to to download
a package of data that includes all
these diverse data types
and right now you can get assembled
genomes for um
all uh domains of life and through data
sets so eukaryotes bacteria and viruses
so how exactly do you get this data
through a web interface we make it very
easy you go to the datasets homepage and
you can just type in
human genome or you can type in also
primase you can go up the tree
and you'll get a box that appears and it
tells you what the reference genome is
and there's a button down here that says
browse genomes and if you click that
browse genomes button
it'll take you to what we call our
genome page and on that page there is a
table
and table will give you all the genomes
for that requested organism
so this is showing all the human genomes
that are available with the reference
genome
sorted to the top you select the genome
that you want
and then you hit the download button and
you have choices of the file
types that you want and you can just
download the data that you need
once you've downloaded the data you'll
see that it is packaged as a
archive as a zip archive um it's called
ntbi datasets by default but you
actually have options to name the file
whatever you like
um and within that file there within
that zip archive there are
all the files that i just described so
you'll see a hierarchy of
sequence and annotation um and
transferred for the
files and i want to point out next that
there's two files
the metadata files that are within this
genome package we have um
some data packages will have just one
metadata file some will have more than
one
um and these metadata files are in json
lines format
which is a good form that's for
bioinformatics foreflows but it's not
necessarily a format that
is human readable so um this is the best
way that
of us we've considered this the best way
to represent the metadata in its
hierarchical format
that's a good way to organize the data
but we know that users won't often want
this data into tabular formats so
datasets actually provides a command
line tool where you can take this json
lines report
and you can convert that into a tsv or
excel file
picking and choosing the data the fields
metadata fields that you need
so i will go over how you do this later
in the talk
so uh i mentioned that we have command
line tools data sets actually have two
command line tools the first one is
datasets and that's for querying and
downloading sequence and metadata
we also have a data format tool and
that's for converting that json line
file into into tsv or excel
our tools are available for windows for
mac and for linux
so what is our command line for
downloading genomes
if you would use our datasets tool that
i just mentioned
and it provides options to download the
dataset by
taxon name by assembly accession or by
bio project id
so our goal is to make things very easy
so our commands are pretty
straightforward it's just data sets
download genome with the command and
then you can do accession
i'll give you the ncbi assembly session
you can use a taxon name
and that could be a common name or it
can be the scientific name
and again you can also enter a
bioproject id
and that will download a default package
of data you also have
options to exclude or include
different files and i'll go over that a
little bit later
for our data format tool again you can
choose
data format and you can choose tsv or
excel
and you can take that that metadata file
that you downloaded and then convert
that into
a geotabular output
so that was our genome package yes our
genome package we also have a gene
package
so a gene includes all organisms with
genes annotated by the refseq project
and the gene package includes the most
current curated gene sets so resting
genes are curated on a daily basis and
so for our genome data set if you
download the scene annotation or
transcripts
you'll get the snapshot of that
particular annotation run this gene
package will give you
access to genes the most current
annotation of any gene in the refseq
collection
so the package includes the gene fasta
sequence
it includes the transcript sequence
includes the protein sequence and again
also a metadata file
in json lines format we also include in
the gene package stsv file which has
a selected number of metadata fields
that you can just
directly download as a table so
like the genome data set we also make it
very easy to
get these gene data sets you just go to
datasets homepage
or you can start from the ncbi home page
type in human
bracket one again you'll get a box that
appears gives you information on
on bracket one and then you have the box
in the size those beautiful table
if you click on that you'll get to this
table that shows you all the transcripts
for that particular gene
and you have options to select different
data columns
you can select all of the transcripts or
individual ones and you have an option
to download a tabular view
or you can download the the dataset that
you use
includes all the sequence and metadata
files
so for genes we also have our command
line tool and again we make it very
simple say data sets
download gene and you can do that by
gene id you can do that by gene symbol
barco 1 and then you can include the
taxon group that you're interested in
you can also download by um refugee
accession so the
nm or np says the transcript and protein
accessions
or you can download the entire gene
dataset for any particular taxon group
so
you can do to gene taxon human and that
will give you all the genes
all the lefty gains for humans
so lastly i'm just going to end this
part of the talk with
encouraging you to go look at our
documentation we have very extensive
documentation that
shows you some quick starts it shows you
how to download the command line tool
has some how-to guides for carrying out
some basic workflows
it also has a metadata schemas
documented
and the description of all these data
packages that i've described and
um it also has uh our public api
documented there and you can if
that's what you're interested you can
see that so now i'm going to go out of
presentation mode for powerpoint and i'm
going to switch over
to a web interface and to show you the
datasets
homepage so this is the datasets home
page
you can find it at ncbi slash datasets
and
the homepage itself will give you
information on what's new
today the webinar and it has three
sections
genomes genes and virus
and lastly our command line tools
so just to show you how we would go and
get
a human genome type in human
and press return you don't even have to
have the word
genome i mean and just you'll get that
box that i described
you can go directly over to the
reference genome or you can click browse
genomes here
if you click browse genomes it brings
you over to
our genome table and then this all the
genomes that are available for humans so
there's right currently there's 892
genomes
if you're interested in just the
reference genome you can click here and
click
download and you'll get all the options
for those files
that i described you can put in your own
name for the genome you don't
it will default to ncbi dataset you have
the option to put
in your own name so that's a straight
download you also have other options you
can
filter so you could filter to just the
reference genome
you could filter to just those genomes
that are annotated
so for human that is grch38 and grch37
you can get to the to the table that's
just including those ones that are
annotated
you can also filter by assembly level so
if you want those that are just a
chromosome level
you can filter the set down by that and
you can also filter by
date if you want to see what's available
with current genomes available
we also have a text filter that filters
by assembly name
or by the submitter so
for example if i wanted to see the new
to t
assembly i could enter that there and it
would filter the list that i'm looking
at
to just that one assembly
so other options that you have in this
table you can go to the actions button
the actions here allow you to do several
things you can view assembly details so
if you want to know all the information
about that as that assembly you can go
over to
the um the assembly page and
you can also go to blast the assembly
and we have a new blast page
and this black page for each assembly in
each row will give you options for
the genome or just the transcripts or if
you're looking at black tea
you can get just the proteins that are
for that particular
assembly annotation so
each these the but the actions here are
specific to
the assembly in that row you can also go
over to our genome data viewer
which will allow you to browse the
genome in a
graphical format there's lots of
functionality there and we have other
tutorials that describe how to use this
viewer if you're interested
and then we also have an option you can
just again get that download widget that
will allow you
to just uh download the information for
that assembly
so you can also multi-select you want to
get more than one assembly
and then you can use the button up here
and that will allow you to
um to get download data for multiple
assemblies
we also allow you to select columns so
you can
select different data types you can add
contagn50 we recently added busco scores
you can get
a species name that's important to you
or buy a project
and buy a sample and you can add those
columns
and if you you have to scroll down a bit
and
use this this bar to scroll across and
see the data for those additional
columns
so if there's any data in this table
that you would like to see that you
don't see now
please let us know we are very
interested to know what
what users are looking for um in these
sort of default columns
and if there's something that you think
is missing please let us know
so if you want to switch to a different
organism or somewhere higher up the tree
you could type in
primates here so we allow you we have an
auto suggest
so you can just start triking in a
common name or a scientific name
and then you can select that from the
auto select
and again you see there's 1039 genomes
for primase
and again once you're there you can sort
for just just the reference ones if
that's what you're interested in
so we have data for for
all organisms so you can also type in
something like vibrio
and there you can get the 15 000 genomes
that we have
for vibrio so the next thing i'm going
to demo
is our gene table so you can just
go back to you can use the search bar
here or you can go back to the landing
page
and you can type in human brs41
and here you'll get a box again that
describes that
information on that particular gene from
human if you go to the full table
you can come over here and you'll see
all the transcripts that are available
for bracket one
and again you can select everything you
can go to download there's an option to
download a table
in tsv or csv format you can name the
file whatever you like you also have the
option to download the data set so that
would include the transcription protein
sequences and the metadata files that i
described earlier
so this is we actually have two views in
this table this is the transcript view
and transfer view allows you to select
columns that are related to the
transcript so you can select
ensemble ids or isoform names things
that reply to
at the transcript level if you switch to
the gene view
you can select columns that are more at
the gene level so you can select
fumble id or omimid
apply those and you'll have additional
columns for
for those that selected data and again
you can select
there's just one here but you could
select many go to download
and you'll get that gene data set or you
can download the table
if you want to add additional genes you
can go to add genes
you can do this by gene id by gene
symbol accession
for symbol you have to enter the
organism name so
i'm going to do example here and ahead
and that will add to the table so you
can add multiple genes you can as many
genes as you like
and you can also switch to the
transcript view that will give you
transcripts for both of the genes that
you selected
and again you have options to download
multiple genes or just one gene
so the next thing i'm going to do is
switch
to our command line so if you just bear
with me for one second i'm going to
switch over to a terminal
and enter okay so
starting from the terminal i'm going to
first show you how to download the data
sets
tool so the first as i mentioned there's
two tools there's the data sets and data
format
so here i'm going to enter the curl
command for
actually for downloading the datasets
tool
download a second command
into this to make it executable so
that's for
for data sets we're going to do the same
for
data format
into the data format curl command and
again make it executable
okay so then okay so now we're ready to
start using the command line
uh and all these instructions are
available in our documentation
so the first thing i'm going to show you
is how to download the human reference
genome so again
data sets download genome examples text
on human
i'm using the flag reference that will
get just the reference genome and i'm
going to name it human
so go ahead and download it the download
should be
fairly fast it should take about a
minute
and if the default download will include
sequence it will include the genomic and
transcription protein sequence
and it will also include the two
metadata files and
the gfs3 file so that should be the
default package and as
after we run this i will show you how
you can use flags to
to exclude or include different files
into your human genome data package
so now we're done now that the file is
done the first thing i'm going to show
you
is how to use that data format tool to
create a table of a few data fields so
i'm going to paste in
this command so it's data format we're
going to look we're going to convert it
to tsv
um it's a genome package um this package
flag
will allow you to well we'll we'll
access the uh metadata files directly
from the download
the download zip file so you don't have
to unzip it first and then i am right
here i'm using a field
flag to indicate a few fields so just
press that
and with the output is the field names
and then the values that are in the
field so if you downloaded
here i'm just downloading a single
genome but if you downloaded many
genomes
you could um you could create a table
that would give you this
this data for for a set of genomes
you can if you don't want to define the
fields you just want to use a default
set of fields
um to convert it you can just do
just use the package flag and your file
and this
is not a very pretty output but it gives
you a default set of fields that are
available in that
genome package so let me
just click this and
make this easier to look at okay the
next thing i'm going to do
is unzip the file so i'm going to use
unzip and clip and
you start to see the files um
unzipping and what you can see here is
that for the
human genome package you're going to see
a different file for each
chromosome past a sequence and they're
going to start to load
we also see that data report that i
mentioned this assembly data report
um it's going to continue to load and
at the end you should start to see the
um the transcript and
there's the gfs file and i believe the
transcription protein files
are here now okay so that's all the
files that are um
part of the genome the default genome
data set
there's also a catalog that describes
the the different file types
okay so next that's our genome package
the next thing we'll show you is if
you're interested in figuring out what
the flags are you can just do
um slash data
download genome
h and so our health documentation um
is lengthy but it shows you example
commands
it gives you information on all the
flags that are available
and it tells you what those flags mean
and how you can exclude or include
different file types it also shows you
how to limit your download to just
reference
or to just um data that's been released
after a certain
certain time so i encourage you to
explore documentation and and
learn more about these flags or contact
us if you have any questions
about it so the next step i'm going to
show is a gene download
and again this is i'm going to download
three human genes
so it's data sets download gene i'm
going to download it by symbol
and i'm indicating that the taxon group
that i want is human and i list those
three
gene symbols and i'm giving it a file
name so
the gene download is smaller package so
it's pretty quick
again i'm going to show you how to use
data format so if you want to pull
out a few fields from that metadata file
you're going to enter this command and
you can again use that package flag
and indicate your file and the fields
that you want and here i'm just getting
gene id
symbol oh and
sorry i have an an ensemble id
sorry there's an issue with it i'll try
next to
demo getting the default package um
so let's see there's a if you use that
package flag
what you're going to get is the default
package of all the fields
uh that's how you can get all the fields
that you want
in the default package if you want to
know what fields are available you can
do
data format
tsv gene
and that will give you here
is a list of all the fields types that
are available up here is the default
fields that are available
using the package flag and then these
are all the fields that you can
you can specifically request using the
fields flags
and the last thing i'm going to show you
here is how to unzip this file
so let's unhip and again you see
the data set includes gene festa
transfer fast a protein past day the
report um the table that i mentioned
that has some default metadata field
and the catalog so that
is the end of my command line demo
um i will go back to my powerpoint
slides and
show you here we have
links to the datasets web pages that i
described in this presentation
i also have listed the command line
examples that i showed please give them
a try
and if there's issues you find or
things that you would like to see there
that you don't see please
definitely contact us contact me and
we would love to hear from you we are
really focused on user feedback so we
want to hear
um hear what will work for you what
doesn't and what we can improve
and lastly i'll just thank my team and
i'll take any questions that are
available
hey noel you also wanted to ask him uh
you had a
thanks for that presentation but you
wanted to ask a poll if you want to do
that now we can do that
sure i uh one thing we're very
interested in is how
people would like to use metadata so i
yeah it'd be great to take a poll now
and see what type of metadata
formats you prefer to use okay so i'm
going to launch a poll and it's going to
ask you
what type of metadata do you prefer and
you can think of the format
and then we'll give it a minute or so to
let people vote
okay
it looks like a spread of this um
sort of the two most common answers are
excel and csv tsp is kind of in the same
ballpark
jason is less popular so okay okay thank
you that's that's really helpful
um yeah and i think that's something
that we are
um we're actively working on and how to
make um
you know we feel that json days and
lines is the best way to
to to represent the data because data is
getting you know increasingly
hierarchical
but um users need a way to to format
that data to tabulate the format so
please try the data format tool um
if it doesn't work for you we would like
to hear from you and
um we'd also like to know what other
ways in which you would like to like to
be able to access that data if it's
directly through the web interface
um we can we can improve those options
yeah we have some questions in the um so
there are a number of different things
um
one of the things that i ran into uh
also nulla was about how to get the cds
and is that something that you're
planning to add for everything or has
that already been added or
because the only way i was able to get
them was um the orthologs
sorry did you get the cvs the cvs
regions cds like coding sequences oh the
cvs regions
yes no i'm glad you asked that that is
something we're actually um doing in
right now we're actively working on so
we are going to provide an option
for users to download the sequence for
just the cds region or
just the utrs if that's that's something
you're interested in
it will probably be a flag in the um
in the command line to just restrict
your fafsa sequence to to cds or to utr
and then after that we'll explore how we
will offer that to people going through
the web interface perhaps there'll be a
download
download option for that type of fafsa
great thank you and eric answered a
similar question in the chat which was
about that
what what things are supported in
bacteria and he said that gene symptoms
apparently support it
for bacteria and that again they were
going to add the
cds regions yeah that's correct
another question has to do with you know
what
we downloaded we worked with the current
reference assembly of human
is there a way i mean that's what you
get by default is there a way to specify
a different reference suppose you wanted
to get the previous one
um if you want so the the we only have
one reference assembly per
per species so if you if you want to get
grch 37
um you can do that by the the best way
would be
by the assembly accession if you're
using the command line
okay um the other option is to to go to
our
our genome table um it's sorted to the
towards the top so you'll see you
clearly see the assembly name grch37 and
you have
the options to download that data
through through the web interface
in terms of you know thinking about what
organisms are supported
so someone wanted to know like for
example how could i do the same thing
for example with cap
could you get the same kind of
information that you got with the human
genome
yeah so you could type in you could type
in cat
and oh that's unfortunate
cat genome um
keyless let's do it let's use honest
suggestions
um you can use that we have some
conflict between
gene symbols and organism names um doing
our best to
to to fix that or make that best
experience but yes if you go to cat
you'll have
see there's all that called the six
genomes that are available for cat
again you can go to the actions menu and
you'll see options to blast the assembly
the data viewer and to download so
also there's a question about the which
i have certainly had
been mystified by over the years at ncbi
is we seem to have some various opinions
about what the
the file type is going to be for
different kinds of sequence
formats and i didn't so he has a
question about
fna which normally to me means fasting
nucleic acid
and he wants to know dot fast a and i
don't know which
what ending we use on david sets when
you download things
we use dot fna and that's the nucleotide
fascism right and so we're using f we're
using the convention of faa for protein
day if we were to get that and saf
reporting correct
is there a general um contact email for
data sets or would we want to use the um
info i do we have this feedback button
on all of our web interface pages um i
definitely encourage use of that
you can just use the info at ncbi uh
the help help desk just indicate you're
asking a question about data sets and
it will work its way up to us um you can
also write to me directly at
larryn a ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
i'm you know owner of the product and
i'm happy to help anyone if they want to
contact me directly
so we have many ways to to reach us but
we read that feedback button every day
it's not a
that's one of these bottomless pits we
actually look at it and please include
your email that's very important so we
can get back to you
and we are very very interested in your
feedback
okay a couple of more things um
so you know there's a lot of health
documentation somebody wants to have
some suggestions about where to go for
help and
read more about this topic okay so
if you are on our our any of our pages
you'll see this menu button at the top
if you select that you can find uh
information on quick starts and command
lines so if i go in there
we'll get into our documentation our
documentation has
um has these quick starts for the
different services that we have
we also have some how-to guides for some
common workflows
like we have a workflow for working with
those json lines for us who's
you know um can you know go go through
here to
the suggestions for the best way to work
with these reports what our
recommendations are
um you will also find a reference
section
that describes if you go to command line
it describes all the um
all the command line flags and filters
things that are available
for all our different services you have
go back to um
we also have um documentation on our
open api
um just as a way of warning we are
actually in the process of versioning
our api
we're on v1 alpha we call it and
we're on our way to a different version
so um
just just as i mentioned we're in very
active development so
um if you come to this page you'll
probably see that there is a version two
at some point
and we will be continuing to develop in
that version too
um and i think that's you know i want to
make that point about data sets in
general
because we are developing so much things
do change um
people don't always like change but um
we are making these changes on
feedback that we're hearing from users
so if you want to contribute to that
again please contact us
so yes all our documentation is here we
have some information on
using different programming languages to
access the api and python and r
steps if that's what you want to work
with
and we are planning a webinar for
september that will be
focused more on programmatic access of
data sets so let's
look for that if that's something you're
interested in
okay another question related to your
discussion of the
or your mention of the programming
languages uh is there
integration into bioconductor which is
an r package i believe
annotation hub is um dimensions
not that i am aware of i will refer
to brad maybe if you uh know much about
bioconductor
i i'll be honest i'm not that familiar
with bioconductor
uh i understand that's a part of our
ecosystem
and we we're working on our our package
we haven't found many people who
want to use it that way yet uh but if
people are interested we'd love to talk
to you
find out what your workflow's like and
make that possible
okay and then there's another question
that i i think i know the answer to but
it's just like
a transcript sequences for prokaryotes
ncbi doesn't really
make transcript sequences per carats
because the nature of
transcription so we don't have that well
we make
we make cds files so cs files based on
the
um on the nucleotide sequence of the
protein so
we don't actually have that in our
package right now but it's something
that we have um
we're planning to include okay i think
that's i think that's everything
and thanks everybody for coming and
thanks dola for the presentation
and so i'll go ahead thank you for this
opportunity and i appreciate everybody
coming it's um
[Music]
it's great to see so many people and i'm
pleased yes send us some feedback